PUCK DROPPED, NASHVILLE WILL
GAIN CONTROL OF THE POINT.
GOOD WORK BY RYAN JOHANSEN AS
HE TRIES TO
WITH A BIG SAFE, NIEDERREITER
BULLED HIS WAY THERE AND SAROS
WILL HANG ON CENTER ICE,
GLOVE DOWN HEBETTER SHOT.
I THINK HE MISSED ELEVAT
CAROLINA TRYING TO GET CLOSE.
>> Mike: BACK INTO THE
NASHVILLE ZONE, KOTKANIEMI WILL
GET TO A LOOSE PUCK ,
YES, KOTKANIEMI, TRY AND SHIFT.
ALONG THE NEAR BOARDS, IT WILL
POP FREE AND FORSBERG INTO THE
CANES AND,  THE BOARD.
INTO THE WELL WITHIN SIGHT, THE
SECOND PERIOD? NTERIOR OF
CAROLINA BEAT  ATTEMPT THAT
DOES GET THROUGH AND ANDERSON
GETS A E,
LET'S LOOK AT THIS, ANDERSON IS
CALM AND COOL IN SO MANY
INSTANCES. LOSE PUCK.
NECAS TRIES TO CLEAR, INEN, SVE
AND THE CANEMAN ADVANTAGE.
FORSBERG AT THTH 1-
ON-1, HIS SHOT IS PUT ON, SAROS
WITH
GRANLUND CAN'T KEEP IT IN,
D'ANGELO MAKE
IN THE CANE'S ZONE, PESCE TRIES
ANDERSON.
NOW IS A TWO GOAL GAME BEAUTIFU
JOSI TO ANDERSON, AND IN RALEIG
SVECHNIKOV, BURIES IT INTO THE